IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
DEMOCRATS IN THE MEDIA LOOKING
LIKE COMPLETE FOOLS AFTER
FALLING FOR ANOTHER MASSIVE
HOAX.
SMOLLETT IS NOW A PROVEN LIAR
AFTER THE CON ARTIST WAS
CONVICTED OF 5 OF 6 CHARGES FOR
STAGING HIS OWN HATE CRIME AND
LYING TO POLICE ABOUT IT.
IT WAS CLEAR TO ANY SENSIBLE
PERSON FROM THE START THAT THE
FACTS OF THIS HATE HOAX DIDN'T
ADD UP BUT THAT DIDN'T MATTER TO
THE NEEDY HEAD, TRYING TO PUSH A
RACIAL NARRATIVE TO DIVIDE THE
NATION.
>> I DON'T LIKE THAT IT IS
PUTTING OUT THERE IN THE MEDIA
THAT THIS IS A POSSIBLE HATE
CRIME.
>> A LOT OF FACTORS BUT I KNOW
THAT JUSSIE SMOLLETT IS A
REALLY, REALLY GOOD GUY.
I JUST WANT JUSTICE TO BE SERVED
IN THIS CASE.
SPEAK OF THE MEDIA HAS REALLY
CAST SO MUCH DOUBT ON HIS STORY
WHICH I FIND SO PERSONALLY OFFE.
>> HE'S GIVEN A DETAILED ACCOUNT
WHICH CHICAGO POLICE SAY IS
CONSISTENT.
HE HASN'T CHANGED HIS STORY.
THEY ALSO STATE IS CREDIBLE, AND
ALSO THAT HE HAS BEEN VERY
COOPERATIVE.
>> THIS IS AMERICA IN 2019.
>> Jesse: DEMOCRATS WERE EVEN
WORSE.
BIDEN SAID "HOMOPHOBIA AND
RACISM HAVE NO PLACE ON OUR
STREETS."
KAMALA HARRIS CALLED IT A
MODERN-DAY LYNCHING AND THE REST
OF THE DEMOCRAT MINIONS WERE
EAGER TO FALL IN LINE.
AFTER PUSHING THIS FAKE NEWS THE
WHITE HOUSE NOW SAYS IT WASN'T A
BIG DEAL BECAUSE EVERYBODY WAS
DOING IT.
WATCH.
>> THERE ARE LESSONS LEARNED
PERHAPS FOR EVERYBODY WHO
COMMENTED AT THE TIME.
INCLUDING FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE RESPECTED THE JURY'S
DECISION, LYING ABOUT SOMETHING
AS HEINOUS AS A HATE CRIME IS
SHAMEFUL.
IF YOU LOOK BACK AT THE TIME IT
IS ALSO TRUE IN IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT ACCUSATIONS OF HATE
CRIMES SHOULD BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY
AND THEY NEED TO BE FULLY
INVESTIGATED, BUT THAT IS WHERE
EVERYBODY WAS LOOKING AT IT AT
THE TIME.
>> Jesse: ACCUSING
PRESIDENT TRUMP OF FALLING FOR
THE HOAX.
>> IN MY OFFICE TODAY WHICH IS
BETWEEN YOU, JESSE AND YOU,
GREG.
>> Jesse: FIRST OF ALL, WE ARE
SORRY.
>> Kayleigh: THANK YOU BECAUSE
I HEAR YOU GUYS A LOT.
YOU MORE THAN GREG.
>> Jesse: YOU CAN HEAR ME IN
MY OFFICE?
>> I CAN HEAR YOU, I SNOOP ON
YOUR CONVERSATIONS.
>> Jesse: OH, BOY.
>> Kayleigh: I HEAR WHAT I
THINK IS THE HARDEST TAKE,
SHAMEFUL CELLS ARE, THEY SAY THE
RIGHT IS GOING TO USE THIS AS AN
EXAMPLE OF WHY NOT TO TRUST THE
MEDIA AND THEN JEN PSAKI SAYS
THIS IS ALL TRUMPS FAULT.
HER BOSS IS THE ULTIMATE RAY
SPADER.
ANY NUMBER OF ISSUES,
MITT ROMNEY WILL PUT THEM BACK
IN CHAINS, THE SHAMEFUL "YOU
AIN'T BLACK" COMMENT IN THE
SHAMEFUL ACCUSATION OF THIS
JUSSIE SMOLLETT CRIME, ONLY TO
BE SURPRISED BY KAMALA HARRIS
WHO SAID THIS IS MODERN-DAY
LYNCHING ALONG WITH CORY BOOKER.
NOT TO TRUMP'S FAULT, SORRY.
>> Jesse: TRYING TO SPREAD THE
GULLIBILITY AROUND LIKE IT WAS
EVERYONE WHO FELL FOR THE HOAX.
IT WAS PRETTY MUCH EVERYONE
AROUND THE LEFT AND LEFT-WING
MEDIA FIGURES.
>> Harold: WHEN THE
ALLEGATIONS CAME ABOUT THEY WERE
EXPLOSIVE, DIVISIVE, ANYBODY
WOULD BE TOUCHED TO THEIR CORE
IF TRUE.
IT TURNED OUT NOT TO BE TRUE.
NO ONE SHOULD NOW DEFEND THIS.
I THINK THERE ARE ACTUAL ATTACKS
BASED ON SOMEONE'S
SEXUAL ORIENTATION COME ACTUAL
ATTACKS, PEOPLE BEING ATTACKED
BASED ON RACE AND EVEN GENDER.
THIS EFFORT HERE BY THIS YOUNG
MAN WHO I DON'T KNOW, I DON'T
KNOW WHY HE DID IT, WHAT WOULD
MAKE HIM DO IT BUT IF
RESEARCHERS AND CASTS DOUBT EVEN
MORE SO ON SOME PEOPLE WHO MAY
NOT BE INCLINED TO BELIEVE THAT
HATE CRIMES ACTUALLY TAKE PLACE.
AT SOME LEVEL I THINK AT HIS
CORE HE PROBABLY WANTS TO TRY TO
ADVANCE THE QUALITY AND HELP THE
COUNTRY MOVE FORWARD ON RACE AND
GENDER ISSUES AND
SEXUAL ORIENTATION ISSUES, BUT
HE SHOVED US BACK HERE.
ANYONE WHO DOESN'T SAY THIS WAS
WRONG IN THE JURY SPOKE IN HE
WILL FACE THE CONSEQUENCES IS
NOT DOING RIGHT BY THOSE IN THIS
COUNTRY WHO WANT TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE OF COLOR, WHO HAVE A
DIFFERENT SEXUAL ORIENTATION ARE
PROTECTED.
>> Jesse: YOU HEARD RACE
RELATIONS IN THE COUNTRY INTO
HAROLD'S POINT, ANY TIME ANOTHER
ALLEGATION OF A HATE CRIME YOU
SEE ON THE TV, PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO SCRATCH THEIR HEADS BECAUSE
THIS WAS SO HIGH-PROFILE IT
RAISES DOUBT EVERY TIME GOING
FORWARD.
>> Dagen: NOT IF YOU SEND THE
MESSAGE OF SENDING
JUSSIE SMOLLETT TO THE -- FOR A
LITTLE WHILE.
>> Jesse: WE MIGHT NOT SEEM
ANY MORE HOAXES.
>> Dagen: JUSSIE SMOLLETT
LEARN TO EXPLOIT RACIAL TENSIONS
FOR HIS OWN BENEFIT AND GAIN
FROM THE VERY PEOPLE YOU JUST
SAW ON THE TV.
WHAT HE DID WAS, HE COULD GET A
YEAR OR TWO.
FIRST-TIME OFFENDER WOULD GET
PROBATION BUT HE COMMITTED
PERJURY ACCORDING TO
ANDY McCARTHY.
HE COULD GO AWAY FOR A COUPLE OF
YEARS.
WHAT HE DID WAS HE PUSHED AND
PEDALED A HOAX DESIGNED TO RIP A
COUNTRY APART THAT WAS ALREADY
TEARING AT THE SEAMS, HE THREW
KEROSENE ON ALREADY A BURNING
FIRE, SO I CALL HIM A CIVIL
UNREST ARSONIST.
HE WAS PERFECTLY HAPPY TO SEE
CHICAGO, THE MURDER CAPITAL OF
THE COUNTRY AND EVEN THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY BESIEGED BY
VIOLENCE, GO UP IN FLAMES,
DESCENDANT OF RIGHTS AND FOR
WHAT?
BECAUSE HE MAYBE WANTED TO PLAY
A SUPERHERO IN A MARBLE MOVIE OR
GET A DEODORANT COMMERCIAL,
BECAUSE HIS TALENT AS AN ACTOR
WASN'T ENOUGH TO GET HIM, WELL,
ANYWHERE, ANYMORE.
THAT IS WHAT WE SEE.
>> Jesse: SOCIAL MEDIA MAKES
IT SO EASY TO FALL FOR THESE
HOAXES BECAUSE HE'S THING AND
THE POLITICIANS THINK THEY HAVE
TO TWEET ABOUT IT RIGHT AWAY.
THEY HAVE TO GET THE MESSAGE OUT
THERE INSTEAD OF JUST WAITING A
COUPLE BEATS.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, I STILL
BELIEVE JUSSIE.
I THINK THEY SHOULD GET TOGETHER
FIND THE REAL ATTACKERS.
ON A REALITY SHOW.
THAT WOULD BE PERFECT.
JEN PSAKI, SHE BROUGHT UP TRUMP
AS AN EXAMPLE, THERE REALLY
WASN'T WHAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT SAYING
THAT IF THIS IS TRUE, IT'S BAD.
IT'S THAT THE PRESSURE TO
SILENCE ANY DISSENT OR
SKEPTICISM IS THE CRIME UNFOLDS.
SO EVERYBODY IS TERRIFIED, WHEN
YOU HEAR ABOUT THIS CRIME, IT IS
SO ABSURD, SO ON THE NOSE, SO
COMICAL THAT YOU BURST OUT
LAUGHING ABOUT ALL THE ELEMENTS.
IT'S LIKE A PERVERSE CHRISTMAS
TREE OF TWISTED ORNAMENTS.
NONE OF IT MAKES ANY SENSE.
BUT IF YOU SAID THAT DURING THAT
WEEK YOU COULD BE CALLED A
RACIST.
AND LIKE DAGEN WAS SAYING.
THIS WAS A VOLATILE CLIMATE AT
THE TIME OF THE HOAX.
SO HE WAS HAPPY TO CAUSE INJURY,
PERHAPS PROPERTY DAMAGE, RIOTS,
WHATEVER IN ORDER TO DO THIS
STORY.
HE HAD TO HAVE KNOWN THAT THIS
COULD HAVE SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES
FOR A LOT OF COMMUNITIES AND
YOU'VE GOT TO REMEMBER, IN THE
THREE WEEKS THAT THIS HAPPENED,
THE THREE WEEKS FROM THE START
WHICH I THINK WAS JANUARY 29TH
TO FEBRUARY 27TH, 18 PEOPLE WERE
KILLED IN CHICAGO INCLUDING A
1-YEAR-OLD AND YOU HAVE TO
WONDER HOW MANY COPS COULD HAVE
BEEN DEALING WITH THAT IN SAVING
LIVES INSTEAD OF DEVOTING ALL
THIS TIME CHASING DOWN THE
IMAGINARY ATTACKERS BECAUSE THEY
WERE SUPPOSED TO.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT SMOLLETT.
I CARE ABOUT THE MEDIA.
THEY ARE JUST AS GUILTY BECAUSE
THEY PRIMED THEIR PEERS, THEIR
FRIENDS IN THE MEDIA AND
ACTIVISTS TO BELIEVE THIS WAS
ACTUALLY POSSIBLE.
THAT YEAH, THERE ARE THESE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS YELLING MAGA AT
3:00 A.M.
NO ONE WOULD BELIEVE THAT IF WE
HADN'T BEEN PRIMED, WHICH WE HAD
BEEN FRAMED MAINLY BY CNN
LETTING US BELIEVE THAT WE WERE
ANTI-POLICE, THAT THIS COUNTRY
IS SYSTEMICALLY RACIST.
SO PRIMED THEM, WHICH IS WHAT
HAPPENED HERE, AND ONE LAST
POINT, IT'S ONLY ONE WAY.
THE TRAFFIC TOWARDS THESE FOLKS
IS ONLY ONE WAY.
THERE IS NO MODERATES, THERE'S
NO CONSERVATIVES, THERE IS NO
LIBERTARIANS THAT FELL FOR THIS,
RIGHT?
IT WAS ONLY THE LEFT BECAUSE THE
LEFT HAS BEEN INDOCTRINATED INTO
THE IDEA THAT THIS IS A
HOPELESSLY RACIST COUNTRY FULL
OF EVIL, WHITE TRUMP SUPPORTERS
WHO JUST WANT TO CHASE ANONYMOUS
ACTORS.
THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO THE GUY
IS.
JESSE'S FAMILY DOESN'T EVEN KNOW
WHO THE GUY IS.
>> Jesse: LIKE THE MAGA
SUPPORTERS WATCH "EMPIRE."
IF THEY ACTUALLY HAD CAPTURED IT
ON THE SURVEILLANCE TAPE, WE
WOULD HAVE SEEN THAT IT WAS
FAKE.
WE WOULD'VE SEEN TWO GUYS
DRESSED LIKE, PULLING PUNCHES.
>> Greg: DON'T HIRE TWO BLACK
EYES TO PLAY TWO WHITE GUYS.
I LEARNED THAT IN ACTING SCHOOL
>> Harold: THAT THREE WEEK
PERIOD, BUT AFTER THAT.
BUT I'M A DEMOCRAT --
>> Dagen: HE ALMOST DIDN'T GET
PROSECUTED.
KIM FOXX DROPPED THE CHARGES.
A WHOLE BUNCH OF CLIPS AND
TWEETS ABOUT JUSTICE HAS BEEN
DONE WHEN KIM FOXX ORIGINALLY
DROPPED THE CHARGES.
>> Harold: I'M ONLY SAYING --
>> Jesse: WHY DID KIM FOXX
DROPPED THE CHARGES?
SHE GOT A PHONE CALL FROM
MICHELLE OBAMA, REMEMBER THAT?
ALL GOES BACK TO THE OBAMA DOES.
EVERYTHING.
>> Greg: WAY TO BLAME OBAMA!